i'm going to be on camera so
hey hold me let me know you come home at
that 7-eleven employer
no i'm not
uh
man how long does it take the cops to
come man
you thought you were talk swinging at
that employee
oh that employee
damn
you smell like freaking alcohol man you
smell you okay if i smell i swear i
won't do anything
to
if you haven't already hit that
notification bell now you know how the
story goes usually when there's someone
connected to islam someone has a name
that's associated with a muslim name
usually gets a lot of negative press but
in this case good samaritan stepping in
to help a store clerk during an attack
on the city's north side there was a
muslim but uh what can you say to
motivate the youth and the dean show's
still waiting for you
sound like that so you come on your body
[Music]
who happens to be a black belt under me
a student of mine also happens to be my
cousin
let me give you guys a little bit of a
background of what happened take a look
at this takedown a good samaritan
stepping in to help a store clerk during
an attack on the city's north side what
takeaways we can take from this i got to
hear from him firsthand so he goes into
the local 7-eleven he's trying to get in
and get out
there's a person in there he's becoming
very
abusive
rowdy he ends up assaulting
the
employee there at 7-eleven take a look
surveillance shows a customer punching
an employee and within the flash you see
idris jump in here's a different angle
of the takedown address tells me trouble
started well before the guy threw the
punch this female walks in complaining
about an individual outside harassing
them now he has to make a decision
what's he going to do he's seeing this
crime being committed right in front of
it it reminded me of the hadith from the
last and final message i said to mankind
problem peace and blessed be upon him
every muslim knows this hadith it says
that if you see an evil he's obviously
seen something evil happening he said
change it with your hands if you can't
change it with your hands go ahead and
speak out against it if you can't speak
out against it if you don't have that
much iman faith
then go ahead the least you can do is to
hate it in your heart in this situation
the muslim who knows this hadith also
wants
good for humanity he wants to protect
his fellow citizen there who's being
assaulted he can do two things do
nothing or do something he did something
he could be somebody who like in this
situation i did a program not too long
ago with hori and gracie where there was
another muslim and unfortunately he also
he was not trained at all
and then immediately he hit me one right
hook mohi's son adele watched his father
fall to the ground here on 70th street
and i've never seen my dad
knocked out in and put in such a
humiliating way like this never
you know and i just
did the loudest deal that i could
possibly do i just like i was so loud
but i wanted to cry i couldn't the
emotional wounds are raw i was
embarrassed
that i couldn't do anything to protect
my father
that this man just trampled in on our
dignity this is another thing we could
take from this you got to go ahead and
be
prepared if somebody's there to attack
you or your family that's why we really
recommend people to learn the art
[Music]
i'm not letting you go man you are
harassing those girls
and
learn this beautiful martial art of
gracie brazilian jiu jitsu red zov jiu
jitsu bone got that 7-eleven employer
was it
[Music]
now so what happens here is
he can do what this person did knocked
out in and put in such a humiliating way
like this who's obviously not trained
and he can just scream at the top of his
lungs i just
did the loudest deal that i could or you
can get trained like he was trained
one of my black belts
my one of my students my cousin is
rodzovic
and he ends up taking this
person to the ground
you thought you were tough swinging at
that employee
one employee employee at 7-eleven right
here
and he puts him in what's a known as a
gift wrap position in the mount position
you smell like freaking alcohol man you
smell you okay if i smell i snake but
you say i swallowed you swamp yes no
i made sure i saw the camera recording
oh no bro
and he's in total control
person tries to escape
[__]
don't try to distract me
i'm not the one bro
[__] don't do this i don't wanna go i
don't wanna
i'm gonna choke you out you're gonna get
it's gonna get worse he's going nowhere
he gets some good advice
well you gotta get a job do you work i
do work what are you working on
[Music]
and we can see
how alcohol is affecting so many so many
people in such a negative way it's
destroying families destroying the most
destroy this person's life this person
could have killed somebody could have
got killed by the employee
you know the cops imagined the cops came
in they would have tased him belly club
to the back of the head to the body
and a lot of people are not trained
properly so i really recommend also the
law enforcement to come and learn from
us to come and learn this beautiful
martial art because now what happens a
lot of times they'll pull out the gun
and things get out of control you don't
know how to control the situation and
someone ends up being dead man how long
does it take the cops to come man
why are you doing like this though
going nowhere
you're gonna get worse if
[Music]
but you can see
how when somebody's qualified someone's
trained how they can go ahead and
control and contain the situation
nice
and relaxed
with confidence just like professor
idris did you say goddamn
like yours
why isn't my life like yours because
how do i got it easy
[__] away from bro
i then went to america where did you go
i came here in chicago where in chicago
where what neighborhood from this
neighborhood
i also grew up in rogers park uptown i
grew up in all those neighborhoods don't
tell me my dad passed it when i was a
little kid i had it rough too
i didn't have a father
father let me go no me neither and i i
didn't make no excuses
everyone had all right let me know i'm
not gonna let you go until the cops come
because you're gonna go here someone
else
i got sons little [__] yeah i got kids
too but you can't be still but you like
this phrases
so we wanted to highlight this because
again you get a lot of press and media
when some deranged lunatics someone
who's out there associated with
has carrying the name muhammad or
ahmed or whoever else and now the press
usually grabs this runs with it and the
fear machine is manufacturing the hate
and the fear but in this case you have a
muslim who helps save
that [__] you need help [__]
don't do me like that [__] i got my own
kid we all got problems
yeah if you're going to hit somebody
you're going to hurt somebody
potentially the life a bad situation
could have got much much worse could
even let to death but a muslim stepped
up risked his life also to go ahead and
save another human being and you see
what's happening nowadays people are
quiet people don't want to intervene you
see it on the subways you see it all
over when something's going down people
turn the blind eye right in front of
them
septa is asking people to step up saying
people need to speak up when they see a
crime happening in front of them while
this woman was being attacked there were
passengers on the train they did
apparently witness what was going on and
apparently did nothing about it attack
was brutal it was wicked and the worst
party when the people were watching
several people watching some within
arm's length says upper darby
superintendent of police whose officers
are investigating the rape of a female
passenger
things can be going down someone can be
being assaulted and most human beings
i'm sure if they knew
this teaching from prophet muhammad and
if they also were well trained they can
do exactly what he did peacefully he
went and defused the situation
made a citizen's arrest held him down
until the police came
too [__] stop this baby
dog i don't wanna look i'm not i'm gonna
i'm gonna go oh
so we wanted to highlight this how a
muslim
who's striving his or her best to be a
outstanding human being
was able to save the situation
[Music]
please man let me go though
i'm gonna get you some water i'm trying
to be nice to you man you could let me
go
extend your arms
extend your arms back
extend your arms back let's go
how a muslim was able to intervene and
peacefully de-escalate the situation
and hopefully this person can also take
that advice give of alcohol and look
into what motivates someone like idris
to go ahead and get involved it's his
deen it's this beautiful way of life
islam submission to the creator not the
creation and living a morally upright
life so go ahead and if you want to
learn more about islam
i'm more than happy to give you a free
gift free copy of the quran and if you
have some questions call us
1-800-662-islam
do not
get your information from the hate
machine come and talk with us
visit a mosque
and inshallah you could be fed the right
information continue to watch the dean
so subscribe if you haven't already and
we'll see you next time until then peace
be with you assalamu
alaikum everyone greetings of peace as
you know there is so much misinformation
being spread about islam and muslims by
the hate machine by the islamophobia
industry that manipulates the masses and
creates this manufactured fear and the
fear leads to hate and we know where the
hate leads that's where the dean center
comes in masjid athletic facility
recording studio live events open houses
public relations educating our brothers
and sisters in humanity being a voice
for the voiceless and the good news is
we are halfway to our goal and we need
your help prayers into ours so we can
get the other half closed on the
property in september inshallah god
willing the rest will be paid off
inshallah over three years owner
financing no interest time is taking
brothers and sisters be a part of
history help make this a reality do your
part donate right now and if you like
this episode of the dean show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum